imagine you're the manager of a
supermarket chain you've noticed that
two things need your immediate attention
the first issue is how to handle the
different kinds of weights that you
encounter at your supermarket the next
one requires you to address the supply
chain issues at the supermarket which
are causing delays to the morning
delivery of milk leading to customer
dissatisfaction and attrition these
problems can be solved by incorporating
two of the most popular quality
management methodologies in the world
lean and Six Sigma one famous for its
ability to handle waste in another known
for process improvement but what if
there was a methodology that combined
the concepts of both Six Sigma and lean
one that could solve all your issues
well there is Lean Six Sigma before we
dive into Lean Six Sigma let's take a
closer look at its parent methodologies
first off lean is a methodology that
focuses on providing value to the
customer eliminating waste continuous
improvement reducing cycle time lean and
Six Sigma both aim to handle waste but
what is this waste waste is any step or
action in the process that a user does
not gain any value from in short things
that users wouldn't want to pay for why
would a consumer want to pay extra for
the additional truck that was required
to deliver milk to the supermarket just
because the other one broke down this
waste can be divided into eight
categories let's have a look at each of
them one transportation this waste
refers to the excess movement of people
tools inventory equipment and other
components of a process than it is
required to inventory this waste occurs
due to having more products and
materials than required this can cause
damage and defects to products or
materials greater time for completion an
efficient allocation of capital and so
on three motion this refers to the time
and effort wasted due to unnecessary
movement of people equipment or
machinery
this could be sitting through inventory
double data entry and so on
for waiting this can be time wasted
waiting on information instructions
materials or equipment five over
production this is the waste created due
to producing more products than required
six over processing it refers to more
work more components or more steps in a
product or service than required seven
defects this is the waste originating
from a product or service that fails to
meet customer expectations eight skills
this waste refers to the waste of human
potential under utilizing capabilities
and delegating tasks to people with
inadequate training for years now many
systems have emerged that use the lean
methodology to identify and handle the
different kinds of waste some of the
more popular and effective ones are JIT
or just-in-time
5s and Kanban the JIT methodology
focuses on reducing the amount of time
the production system takes to provide
an output and the response time from
suppliers to customers 5s is another
methodology that focuses on cleanliness
and organization while improving profits
and efficiency Kanban is also another
popular methodology to achieve Lane it
is a visual method to manage tasks and
workflows Kanban enables users visualize
the workflow to identify issues in the
process and fix them these methodologies
help in optimizing the waste production
and are often used together to maximize
results so that's the first problem
solved now let's have a look at how you
can improve this supermarket supply
chain efficiency for that let's have a
look at the other part of Lean Six Sigma
Six Sigma Six Sigma is a set of tools
and techniques that are used for process
improvement and removing defects let's
see how Six Sigma makes that possible
Six Sigma has two major methodologies
DMAIC and
DMA TV you can learn more about these
two methodologies by checking out our
six sigma in nine minutes video by
clicking on the top right corner let's
have a closer look at DMAIC since Lean
Six Sigma uses the DMAIC methodology of
Six Sigma DMAIC is an acronym for define
measure analyze improve control it is
used to improve existing products and
processes so that it can meet the
customers requirements in the define
phase you determine what the goals of
the project are in this case you want to
reduce the amount of time taken to
deliver milk from the warehouse to the
supermarket so that it is stocked on the
supermarket shelves before 8:30 in the
morning in the measure phase you measure
the performance of the current unaltered
process the milk truck leaves at 7:30
a.m. in the morning and can take one of
three routes a B and C relay is
currently the preferred one as it takes
only 60 minutes to reach the supermarket
compared to the routes B and C which
takes 70 and 80 minutes respectively in
the analyze phase you find out why the
defects exist since routes B and C were
school bus routes by reducing the
starting time by 1 hour at 6:30 instead
of 7:30 meant avoiding the traffic
routes B and C now take 40 to 45 minutes
to reach the supermarket route a still
takes the milk truck one hour to get to
the supermarket even when the truck
leaves at 6:30 a.m. in the improve phase
performance can be improved by
addressing and eliminating the root
causes
now that you've realized that advancing
the milk pickup by an hour and changing
the route to route B can save time you
change the process accordingly providing
your workers with ample time to stock
the milk into the shelves before the
morning rush and finally in the control
phase you make regular adjustments to
control new processes and future
performance you continue to monitor the
delivery times and try out alternate
routes to continually improve the
process and ensure even faster delivery
this process changed led to reduced
man-hours
and cost enhanced sales and customer
retention the Lean Six Sigma methodology
offers many such benefits to businesses
let's take a look at some of them one
increase in profits to standardized and
simplified process 3 reduced errors for
employee development 5 value to
customers and that is Lean Six Sigma for
you now before we're done we've got a
quiz for you which type of waste refers
to the time and effort wasted due to a
necessary movement of people equipment
or machinery a inventory be waiting C
overproduction D motion leave your
answers in the comment section below for
a chance to be one of three people to
win an Amazon gift voucher we hope you
found this informative and helpful if
you enjoyed this video a thumbs up would
be really appreciated
don't forget to subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update on the latest
trending technologies thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
you